hi I'm Nirmal Makka pakka I'm a kernel
developer here at goal from research and
my talk today is about complex valued
visualizations in building language
hello everyone I work in the
visualization team and today I'm going
to be talking about complex valued
visualization in the Wolfram language so
in version 10 we introduced two famous
complex plots Julia said plot in the
Mandelbrot set plot and in this version
we are going to release a set of five
plots which will help you visualize
complex numbers and complex functions in
2d and 3d so these are built on top of
our existing visualization functions and
some of them are convenience functions
but all of them are very useful in handy
so we have re-employed ABS art plot and
then we have three plots on the complex
plane so in this talk I will walk you
through what these plots do and then
we'll take a look at a couple of
examples so first up is re-employed and
this one takes a function and plots both
the imaginary part as well as the real
part of the function so whereas plot for
example of a function like square root
of x will just give you the real part
re-employed will give you both the
imaginary and the real parts and it will
style the imaginary part slightly
differently than the real part now for a
simple example like this you can of
course do it with plot just split the
real and imaginary parts and plot them
but if you have multiple functions and
especially if you have overlap between
the real and imaginary parts it's going
to be somewhat tricky to keep the styles
straight and so that's why I having a
function like this would be handy and we
also optimize the different options for
these plots so for example you have you
get a special value for plot legends and
a couple of new options like reom style
and real Able's which split the labels
for the real
imaginary parts so you get get a nice
plot next one is ABS arc plot and this
one will plot the absolute value of the
function and color it by the value of
its argument so if you look at the plot
of the absolute value of this function
you'll see that it matches the shape
that you get for ABS art plot and then
what it does is it takes the argument
values of the function so you can see
that in this case you only have two
values it's a step function and then
it'll map those values to the color
scheme which comes from the color
function and then it will match up the
values so you can see here that on the
left for the negative x-axis you see
that sort of mustard color which matches
up on the legend with PI over two and on
the right you get the emerald which
matches up with zero so the same thing
is illustrated here with a plot of the
argument of function you can see that
it's the step function and and I'm
essentially doing the same thing here
with color function by rescaling the
value which is argument on x-axis to
live between negative PI and PI and then
applying the color function to that this
of course is a bare-bones sort of
function and yeah it's easier to just
talk about two colors so that's why I
picked this one but this function really
shines when you have functions that have
dramatic changes in their face so here
are a couple of examples the bottom is a
combination of sine functions and the
top is the zeta function and so you can
see the absolute values are being
plotted and you can pick the colors and
from the flowers you can infer the
argument
so next up is complex lists plot this is
the plot corresponding to this plot on
the complex plane and it will take a
list of values and plot them on the
complex plane it's easy enough to do it
with list plot just do the real and
imaginary parts of the number and you
can plot it but again it's convenient to
have a function that plugs into the rest
of the system so if you're doing things
like solving for the roots of an
equation and they turn out to be complex
you can simply plug them in to complex
plot and plot them and here at the
bottom is another example of eigenvalues
of a PDE problem and again you can just
plug it in and make it work that is of
course one aspect of complex plot the
other aspect is like I said the
customization of options so here we can
do something interesting we can just
pick a sampling of complex numbers and
plot them but I'm coloring each of those
points by their argument and we can of
course do that because color function
will take argument as one on one of its
values
come complex list it indicates the left
bottom and the top right corners region
for the points list point list plot or
yeah we will get to the function part of
this but yeah so so that's so here's
another way of doing the same thing and
here I'm just doing the calling them by
the argument of the inverse of the
function so then the question becomes
can we sort of generalize this in some
way where we can plot the function in
the complex plane and color it by the
argument and that's what complex plot
does so complex plot takes a function a
complex function and and then it plots a
function and colors it by the argument
the same two examples that you see saw
on the previous slide here with the
function complex part of Z and one over
Z so what is advantage of coloring a
complex function this way apart from
being able to read out the argument in
the color it turns out that this kind of
coloring scheme will help you identify
zeros poles and essential singularities
on the function so if we take the first
function the first plot here there is a
zero at the center and if we take the
color scheme the endpoints of which the
start and end points are red and violet
and so the colors change in a
counterclockwise direction starting from
red and going all the way to violet and
that's how you can identify that there
is zero there and when you have a pole
the orientation of the change of colors
and now the Reds the colors change from
red in a clockwise direction to violet
apart from being able to tell if there
are zeros or poles we can also tell how
many of these zeros and poles we have
and so here is an example with three
plots and the first one has two the
second one has three and the third one
has four poles and so the color cycle
multiple times so the first example with
two poles the to zero sorry
the colors go from red to violet and
again from red to violet twice this
should be fairly obvious why that is the
case but it's still sort of fun to look
at it on a man manipulate so here's
example with four poles four zeros and
if we pull the zeros apart you can see
that each one of those zeros has the as
the color cycle associated with it so
you have the red going to violet so when
there is this coincidence of these zeros
you get that color cycle for essential
singularities the pattern is slightly
different and so you have the colors in
this case going you have this ring
pattern for the colors and the colors
change along the diagonal from left
bottom to the top right and goes from
red to violet this way so that's how we
read color in complex plot but we can
also add more information to this plot
and we can add the absolute value of the
function to this plot and the way we do
it is by shading the plot so we apply
shading on top of the color and the
mechanism by which we do it is to use
the color function and for this plot the
color function is slightly different it
it's a list where the first element of
the list is
the traditional color function and the
second element is a shading scheme which
I'm going to get to in just a second
but if it turn off the color function
and let the shading scheme do its
automatic thing you can see that there
is a pattern being applied to the
function and if we do a 3d plot of the
absolute value you can see that that
shading pattern matches the absolute
value of the function so if we put all
these layers together we get the complex
plot of the function where the function
is being plotted it's being colored by
its argument and shaded by its absolute
value and the legend shows you what
exactly is happening so there's the left
part of the legend will tell you how the
function is being shaded by the absolute
value and the right part will tell you
how it's being colored based on the
argument so then we come to the shading
scheme so this is a snapshot from the
documentation for complex plot and it
lists a bunch of shading schemes we have
the names shading schemes and I'm not
going to go through the details of the
shading schemes that this table will
tell you what they're attempting to do
so it's it's turns out it's a good idea
to have many of these shading schemes
because the shading scheme is trying to
give you an impression of the change in
the absolute value not all shading
schemes work well with all functions so
it's good to have a few of these so you
can pick the one that works best for the
function that you're trying to visualize
but I'll just show you a gallery of
these shading schemes with applied to
the function that we're discussing and
[Music]
yeah this will give you an idea of the
variety of shading schemes that we have
so that is complex plot so a natural
extension to this would be complex plot
3d because we get one extra dimension so
we don't have to resort to shading ski
to to convey absolute value so you can
directly plot the absolute value here as
the third dimension and as you can see
you the shape of the function matches
the plot 3d of absolute value of the
function and the color matches the
change the the phase shift of the
function when plotted when compared with
the plot of the arc of the function so
one thing to mention here is that the
endpoints of this color scheme that are
chosen by default or the same so that's
why you don't see a line along along
there where there is a dramatic shift
here in the argument but if you pick a
function color function that has
distinct endpoints then you can see that
branch got in a much more dramatic
fashion so one option that is worth the
special mention here is mesh and because
mesh is slightly more useful in a 3d
plot they've taken advantage of that to
assign values to mesh function and so we
can plot we can plot real imaginary in
absolute value and argument and we can
draw mesh lines based on those values so
you can of course mix and match these so
I guess that's the end of my talk I
conclude with that and yeah sorry for
using the boring function but these
plots really produce stunning
visualizations and our documentation is
full of them so if you have the
conference beta I encourage you to take
a look at them thank you
you